onie in Indiana how are you Tony well
it's a life that hassle how can how much
more can I say without that I think you
covered it how can I help
hey I make 32 grand a year I'm about
$60,000 in debt I've completely keep
completing baby step one but then I live
with my dad and my dad's not so good
with the money and about he owes me
about 30 grand a lot of the my parents
cause off 15 to 20 grand each and
they're both in my name because of their
divorce which was about money they
actually took me to you a class when I
was like 11 which is how I remembered
you but family they didn't learn
anything from it I need to figure out
how I can go about this get my dad to
stop borrowing stuff because it's got me
my credit cards are mostly maxed out
because I helped having to help him out
because my thousand dollars is gone how
old are you just turned 27 and how old
is he 46 and the car he's driving is in
your name yeah it's a Ford f-350 Super
Duty truck he told me well restart my
business that I had up in Michigan in
business actually did quite well so I'm
like okay we can be started but things
keep happening and it didn't do well you
got thirty-two thousand dollar income
and your parents no $50,000 on cars that
are in your name this is insanity
Santa's random student I got about six
grand in credit card debt
fifteen grand in student loans which I
took out to help pay for my sister's
private Chris when are you gonna stop
trying to fix your family I don't know
I'm bad it I'm too generous of a person
people are generous you're an enabler
I'm idiot yeah no no I didn't say you're
an idiot are you you have a big heart
you're a sweet person yeah it's hard to
say no when they framed as we're going
to lose all gonna lose out down if we
don't find a way to come up with some
money so well you're all gonna lose
everything they're gonna take you with
them yeah so no starts today so yeah
it's an easy word it's a it's an ancient
word and it is a powerful word you press
your tongue towards the top of your
mouth you release it you
we're past your lips and it sounds like
this no yeah no yeah you don't learn
that word you're gonna be bankrupt
yeah you're not loving your parents well
you are participating in their insanity
yep
you're not helping them you're harming
them stop harming them stop it
that's for your good man I love you
don't go don't this is hurting you it's
hurting them stop it